it's just it's just my face just looks
look i look like a giant compared to the
two of you
like you're you're just two tiny women
and i am
and
if this is in the episode everyone this
is what alarma says to us before every
recording i need you to know that i am a
giant compared to both of you you're
both replaceable compared to you that's
what you say every single day i think
it's i think it's cruel i will have
grant kirkhope on my channel every time
austin misses an
episode seriously the retribution so
instantaneous
to be clear it was unrelated
my audio is massive oh clearly not
beginning of the recording and i
apologize it's what um my audio is
massively blown out of the starter
recording i'm just apologizing that for
us this is going great everything's fine
it's professional it's professional
podcast professional podcast it was
interesting talking to uh grant versus
you austin because he kept his approach
to talking about things was so different
and he kept being like i don't know i'm
not some like intellectual composer like
austin wintery
it's like i don't know what that means
i don't know what that means
yeah i
grant is the sort of
king of self-deprecation i guess um
he's always thing in fairness yeah
yeah he's always he's always
from literally the first time we ever
met it was it was a non-stop onslaught
of comments like that you know it's just
well i mean it's not like i know what
i'm talking about but i love it or
whatever
and meanwhile as we stand around some
convention and people
come up to him just exploding and
fawning over him like i i like might i
don't have a childhood that's
you know that's what i said to him
that's grant free yes it's a
non-sequitur
uh interesting talking to somebody um
like grant coco for anyone listening who
doesn't know grant kirkhope was a
composer at rare
in the 90s most known for the tick tock
golden eye pause music the pause music
that went viral uh banjo-kazooie
banjo-tooie perfect doc
um goldeneye dk rap uh and then went on
to do mario rabbids kingdom battle and i
think that's what he's working on right
now
and um kings of ammore and a whole bunch
of stuff um and yeah i recently
interviewed him on the channel and it
was funny the amount of comments that i
got from people who didn't understand
his
yorkshire accent
he speaks really fast and they're like i
don't know what he's saying
but um it is funny to think about
that
who those people are going to be now i
feel like there are so many female
musicians right now who are very popular
people who are younger than i am who
credit justin bieber for so much that
it's like damn like there's um
you know about that family
who
all of the children there were maybe
like nine of them or something were all
locked in one house for their whole
lives and never allowed out sometimes
chained to beds
i mean i remember there have been
various stories along these lines i
think it was in like vienna or somewhere
there was a story of someone who was
locked like a family that was trapped
for decades um
but i don't remember as many as nine
i could be wrong about the amount it was
a lot of kids though um and yeah they
were locked and chained to their beds
while their parents were like out living
you know their dream lives and and these
kids didn't know any different um but
one of the weirdest parts of it was that
the parents would buy loads of toys and
clothing for children but would never
actually let their children wear any of
them and it's like
the idea that they really wanted to
present as though they had this happy
family and and fantasize about it but
they were actually literally chaining
their children to beds and and they were
never allowed to go outside they're all
malnourished um they can't speak
properly uh
and
one of them
eventually broke out and called the
police she had like managed to get a
phone for sure brie larson won an oscar
for this uh adaptation of this stuff oh
really
i mean i'm kidding but she did
not see room it was like she oh right i
have not seen room no that's basically
the premise of this movie except this
show has gone through some tonal changes
well i'm circling back to
justin bieber is that the girl who broke
out and called the police
um
she credited finding justin bieber
to realizing that there was a world
outside of
her house that she really wanted to find
and she had like seen two of his music
videos and basically like
internet fell in love with him and that
was her motivation for breaking out of
the house and getting all of her
siblings out
um
yeah
it's not a bad contribution to the world
on his part then i know
not so bad like billy eilish always
talks about justin bieber uh you know
and mine's grant kirkhope so what you're
describing basically alana is aging is
suddenly you notice that like there's
been two three generations since you
were a kid yeah you might be wrong
experience i've only just noticed yeah
yeah
yeah i mean yeah that's worse with
age-old but like i love
uh miyamoto and i think that we all do
and i don't know that there's a miyamoto
too yet unless it's kojima but
i don't know that that would they will
they're far enough apart i mean to a kid
nowadays it's more likely to be notch
isn't it or um
that kind of generation because there
isn't really a fortnight version of that
that was insane
like a generation out in public up
around fortnight is it horton doesn't
really
i mean obviously there it has a director
it has game designers and directors but
i don't feel like they're known in the
way notches
yeah
it's not out there in the same way and i
know like
roblox
i'm sure i've said this on the show
before about how uncomfortable i find it
that roblox makes so much money and is
consuming so many children's time uh to
the extent that some people are
considering it like
child labor law issues with roblox um
but no adults i i know use it
yeah there's there's uh the anyone who
watch i'm sure people a lot of people
who watch this watch this as well but
people make games dudes have done a
couple of videos on it which were
fascinating
yeah there's
about roblox yeah there is literally
like an a marketplace of yeah like you
say 14 year olds basically making
content
which is then sold and then they don't
actually make you know there's basically
a cut being taken by the company that
makes the game from that
and at that point you kind of are
employing children or you're at least in
business with children which is legally
a very very very isn't that the same
though i mean if there's a difference
like
etsy
or ebay hosting people's ability to sell
their stuff is not the same as employing
them isn't this more analysis sure but
you legally wouldn't as etsy wouldn't
etsy will absolutely in their terms of
service say you must be overweight to
have a credit card that's a fair point i
don't yeah i don't know how that
i don't know how that works it's
different because there's an inclined
currency that they so that's what you
earn you're earning the in-game currency
and then just spending again
then you can cash out your in-game
currency but there's some fantastically
weird rules about how that's done it's
it's definitely worth watching the
the much much more knowledgeable people
than me talking about it but yeah the
people people make games
i feel like i don't know enough about
roblox that's saying that's yeah that's
an hour of just a deep dive interviews
with the developers you'd be into i
think yeah
that game is probably the number one
example of
of sort of i guess it's from aging but
whatever it is that makes me
have that epiphany one day where i
realize there's like a hundred million
kids and multi-billion dollar thing
that's just a hundred percent off my
radar i think a lot of folks my age
that's roblox roblox has been that one
where you just go it's like when there's
some pop star that wins you know the
song of the year at the grammys and
you're like i've never heard of this
person and this literally apparently had
the number one
you know achievement this year in music
and i just literally
totally they i mean they have different
celebrities kids these days i'm just
gonna say like there are tick tock stars
that i don't know
who are
like on alan in the same way that an
actor used to be and it's like oh um
even
even like gamer youtubers i was
introduced to um ninja or something and
i had no idea who he was and i was just
chatting away like to this like quite
shy kid this was a few years ago but
like just the number of like big
youtubers who you meet totally who like
you find out later are big names but
like to you were just you know
a kid and an interesting enough kid that
you talk to it's weird it's weird we're
getting old and it's horrible i know
that any any warhol quote that um i
sadly don't remember the quotes i'm
going to misquote it while referencing a
quote
something along the lines of you know in
the future everybody will be famous for
a minute 15
yeah and i
feel like that's pretty well true
it's 15 minutes of fame it's 15 minutes
i didn't realize that andy warhol was
the origin of that well i don't know if
that is the exact same as the 15 minutes
of fame
claim
or if they come from different but he
said it i think it was an observation he
made i'm gonna have to google that
austin you're already googling it i feel
like it's my fingers it's correct no i
can't because the way i'm recording
today i can't i can't pull up i think
it's a warhol
but every the reality is every quote is
not from the person you think it is
that's true uh but it feels like it's
correct that that
misattributed to him yes there you go
i was sad it was
two other people said it in reference
to his work like they were taking the
piss out of him basically from the
sounds of it if i'm reading this wrong
um
but yes that's the ultimate long-term
win that he then gets credited with the
quote that's
that's ideal you know what i don't think
it was sarcastically he was quoting
someone in a program for one of his
galleries but that's faded from history
but anyway it's it's tr i think you are
right alan i think there we are at that
stage now well there's for better or
worse there are so many people who are
famous in so many different ways that
you might never have heard of them and i
feel like that just keeps getting more
and more varied and that like there
could be somebody who's famous for being
on netflix but then there's somebody
who's famous being on hulu and people
don't have access to all of the same
shows even and then there are yeah like
youtubers that sometimes i've met at
parties who all go on to find out
you know 10 million subscribers or
whatever and i'm like what
there's so many of them in a way that
like we all have these different people
who are famous for different subcultures
like uh
last week or maybe earlier this week
um the people who are
the
two
uh the best i i'm not qualified to talk
about this i don't know about it it was
just a friend is very into it um speed
runners for spelunky
uh one of whom is american and one of
whom is i believe korean um
they they have like a community around
the the speedrunners who like try to i
don't know if you haven't played splunky
but it's [ __ ] hot i love it though um
who you know get through the game as
fast as they can or whatever and
the korean guy i believe is like very
involved in the community of spelunky
speedrunners but the american guy is not
um even though he's you know very
successful and they would all know of
him he's not actually like involved in
that community and doesn't necessarily
talk to them
and he recently did a stream where he
did like public matchmaking and the
korean guy happened to match with the
american guy so for the first time ever
those two are playing spelunky together
live and that whole community is
freaking out like it's the best thing
that's ever happened to them like this
holy grail moment that they've been
waiting for for such a long time that to
us is like oh there's two guys please
like
like it's something that you just can't
even
i wouldn't have even known about it if i
didn't just have one friend who's very
into splunky and i find that kind of
cool like how how
diverse our subcultures have gotten like
i think that's part of what th to th
this ties back to what you asked about
the
what is the thing what is the game that
10 years from now or 15 years from now
the young adults will be saying that was
the foundation of my childhood and i
feel like there won't probably be
one sort of the way that the n64 seems
to have cast such a massively long
shadow
uh when it first came out and so many of
the things like gold and i like
uh mario 64 mario kart that really just
don't oh yeah really we're such a huge
part of so many millions of people's
kind of
consciousness forming as they emerge out
of adolescence around that time
right now the options are so wide and
there's like you said there's someone
who can have 50 million followers on
tick tock that the broad that other
outside of those 50 million people no
one has ever heard of so they're hugely
seminal for
you know the upbringing if these people
are kids now they'll look back at some
tick tock person go you know they've
changed my life they're i'm a musician
now because of them or i'm an actor
because of them or blah blah blah
and and we've never heard of them and i
feel like because of the way technology
there's so few gatekeepers and there's
also just
fewer
things you know or more things rather
there were fewer things you know whereas
before it was you know
gaming wise at least you had n64 you had
genesis you know
what saturn the m64 is also interesting
there because the n64 didn't actually
sell that well
it's that the party games worked for
four kids to go to somebody's house and
play them at once you only needed one
friend to have an n64 for you to have
that vehicle party or childhood with
like mario party and mario did it not
sell well in my i mean it did but not as
well as you would think considering how
pivotal we
place it as yeah like if i let me look
yeah it was so huge to me that and all
my friends well no not all my friends
but there was definitely like two or
three of us that had it and therefore
everyone had you know everybody yeah
everybody had their go because yeah you
know we would all
pass them around and obviously four
player
gold and i
i saw somebody respond on twitter in
response to the grant thing where they
were like this can only be solved by
uh you know license to kill on slappers
only or something like that and i
thought i thought
i i once upon a time i would have been
unbeatable
and now i'm like
this you know old man yells at clouds
trying to i played golden eye on an n64
a couple of years ago for the first time
in ages and i was like holy [ __ ] i'm bad
at this now it's also just terrible like
thank god for rare replay which is so
good because it's also hard to go back
and play banjo kazooie on the n64 um
it's hard to play all those games jet
force gemini was terrible until they
brought it out on rare replay and now
it's actually playable um so for
reference the nintendo 64
now
um has sold 32 million units
which is a lot but i feel like i need to
get other consoles to compare that too
yeah give us like ps4 comparison
like a couple of hundred or something
right like yeah a couple of hundred yeah
just just like 200 people at ps4s
no i know i know you mean millions
100 million playstation 4. i'm sure bro
ps2 is a 155 million
yeah wow well my sense of calibration
ps4 116. that that's shocking really oh
i'm wrong then so it's not it was
actually lower ps4 100 yeah ps2 is still
the the highest selling um and then the
ds family and then the game boy and the
game boy color so if i get the big ones
playstation 4 is 116. nintendo switch is
92 playstation 3 is 87 xbox 360 is 84.
so like that paints a picture of how far
down the the um nintendo 64 is funnily
enough nintendo 64 is below game and
watch
you know
you know what i find
strange about those statistics is that
when i when a game
a god of war or last of us or uh ghost
of fashima comes out and they talk about
you know we sold 10 million units or 15
million units it's crazy to think
how small that is of the overall
console bay i would have thought that
those numbers would be closer together
and therefore my assumption was that the
total console sales
you know the number of units
like if 50 million people own ps4s and
of those 15 million bought you know last
of us or something
that feels like it kind of scans to me
but the idea that it would be those
numbers against a hundred
and ten i want to look at what the
highest selling surprisingly yes i don't
know why difference is
so i was thinking that yeah
um so the highest selling sale isn't a
sale isn't a sale yeah because it was
sold to a store um i do get that uh you
know also the timeline as well right
like the timeline you have a console you
might buy a ps4 at launch
but then by the time the big hitting
games at the end of its life cycle are
coming out you've moved on or you've
you've left home or you've passed it on
to a
partner or a sibling and yeah still the
same games as you like it's
it's it's not just a a money thing it's
a time thing as well it's wednesday just
doesn't mean you're into it as a measure
of ecosystem though it's just surprising
to me that there could be that many ps4s
floating around and yet so many so few
of those
like one mega hit title
being itself a surprisingly small
concentration of that overall pool yeah
i agree because they and intuitively to
us they seem so big um
so i don't know if this is including pc
sales but supposedly god of war
has sold 19.5 million copies i had
thought that spider-man was the highest
selling but it this list um this is just
wikipedia so it's obviously not a great
source says god of war is the highest
selling at 19.5 million but that's
compared to 116 million owners
that it does seem it's not even 50 it's
so so it's a few things so it's also
it's also resale remember so a lot of
you know if you think about how big the
second-hand market is as well you can
probably
just to start with especially
that's what the days gone director did
is that what that is that would explain
those numbers disparities is that what
that meant
wasn't
thing just that it was like so dave's
gone he based it on how many trophies
people had had had gotten
ah
yeah which means he was he was doubling
or something it was discounting the
amount of people who would have bought
the game secondhand sounds like so in
other words it was an apples to oranges
comparison then because
it's like if you're comparing trophy
numbers to first-hand market
sales units you're
not really i strongly believe that if
they had have sold eight million units
sony would have done the thing that sony
does every time the game sells eight
million units i don't know why they're
so focused on eight million where they
would have said something um they would
have tweeted it out
but they didn't
it could also though another thing
that's worth remembering and this is
something that's often forgotten with
video games l statistics is there's a
difference between your sales like
initially during like the period where
you would be marketing and then the kind
of slow sales afterwards so it's
possible that it didn't hit if it if it
did hit in the timeframe
it didn't hit it it hit it after they'd
done a discount on the on the pfl
it could have been yeah it could have
been that they hit that that milestone a
point where it would be where they would
be inviting kind of critics and
commentators to go well yes it sold a
million but look at what the you know
there
decision not to you don't tend to boast
about your numbers years after release
or even six months after release because
i mean it only came along
they did it with ghost of tsushima and
days go on and go sushima did not
release that far apart
did they release in the same year
no day's called the scene was maybe the
other end of the year this was before it
i thought by at least a year or two yeah
i think i think it might have been the
year before because i think i think goes
to sushima came out in june
july july oh
okay they are your pot then go sushima
was july 17 2020 and i i know the last
of us was like a month beforehand it was
cheap right
yeah so every number you've ever heard
or everything you may have today the
audience has ever heard is usually not
the total number it's like the number
that happened early in the release of
the thing when they were still marketed
that's like how i remember you know how
famously the the
elizabeth taylor cleopatra from the 60s
was like one of the biggest flops in all
of history you know it was
massively massively epically expensive
movie at the time and and essentially
lost its shirt
and uh but i remember seeing a headline
in like 2010 or something that said as
of today that movie has broken even uh
which was
so it was something like that i remember
when that
i probably had way off on what year that
was but i remember saying it's like over
you know half a century of dvd sales or
whatever and like playing on cable and
license fees every few years
it very slowly
uh earned back its money you can see and
you can see these platforms if you're a
triple a studio you're or a platform
holder that's making triple a games you
do need to find as much revenue as you
can because they're getting they're only
getting more expensive you know which
makes you know makes decisions to pull
to pc for example make some sense in
that context that you've got to get as
much revenue out the back end of the
game as you can
but it just goes to show that
semantically
semantically we would still consider
cleopatra failure even
say it actually isn't though it just
took an ungodly amount of time that's to
your point like a game that the game
that sort of has a rough start
um but this is where it's interesting
because you yourself talk about how
thomas was alone didn't explode out of
the gate but i don't think we look at
that and say it's a failure so why is
there something like bastion was
famously the same thing it took the
steam it took a seam either summer
or fall sale i think it will link it
it was
i think that was its first time on sale
on xbox it was on summer of arcade or
whatever it was called whatever it was
it launched
weekly and then once it had some initial
little sale after a month or two or
three or four or whatever it was
um and it reached its critical mass and
then the word of mouth blew up and then
suddenly it became bastion so the
reality is if bastion or thomas was
alone was sold as but were made by big
studios with investors they would be
seen as failures
especially because those games exist
outside of the hyper-capitalized
true it didn't matter
company incorporation yeah
if it did if they'd happened at big
places that would be seen as a failure
did the journey by definition you just
spent long
journey broke playstation network uh
immediately sales records wow how
because it it it just
it was one of those i think where
the it helps that the reviews were
yeah just like they were just like
stupid you know they were they were you
you couldn't pay for reviews like this
correct
it was literally like if you if you paid
someone to do it they would write
something less impassioned than the
actual one it was so
wild how strong the response was and
then and then yeah people uh just it
just it just shot out of the gate you
know because i don't know how much
pre-launch hype it had there was
definitely curiosity because it was a
now it was out there was announced i had
i had written a blog
entry for the playstation blog about the
music like two months before it came out
well received as well right
considerably more so i mean flower oh
did flower come out before journey
yeah yeah flower was the middle in my
head that's the other way around
interesting okay now we did flow in 2005
initially as students and then as a ps3
game ps3 launch title that we were late
for
uh in 2006 uh bri
you know dripping over into seven
and then they they jumped straight into
flour and they did flour which came out
in 2009 and then we immediately started
work on journey and it took three years
and came out 2012.
so yeah that bit of momentum behind you
which is great you had the marketing of
sony and you had great reviews because
your game was excellent obviously so
it's kind of those things kind of gave
you all sorry that kind of rolling
snowball of of success right and it was
also obviously
you know 2012 the volume of titles
coming out on a daily basis was a
fraction of what it is now so i always
look at it and i say
journey
was
very much a right place right time i
think where that you know that exact
game
today would uh
you know probably have to fight a lot
harder to get found you know and and
and uh
it's just one of those one of many
things that makes me occasionally go
holy [ __ ] how lucky how how sort of not
nothing any of us can take credit for
that those variables came to another
hilarious thing as a side note is
um
because the game has is so sparse in its
content in terms of like there's no text
or voice over or or you know it's it's
so just
visuals and and
audio and the audio is so dominated by
the music i remember
you know we had prepared these tracks
for a soundtrack album i'd edited the
in-game music to to make it out to make
it hopefully a nice album and we were
sitting on it and genova goes
i think we shouldn't release the album
the same day as the game because if
someone were to listen to the album and
then play the game it's kind of a
spoiler
like because it walks you through the
emo the game leans on the emotions
provided by the music so much that
you're basically getting
half the game handed to you without the
other half as opposed to normally when a
soundtrack would probably be less than
half the total experience on a typical
game but this was an unusual one so he's
like i feel like it's sort of
emotionally a spoiler so we should give
the
album you know give the game a week or
two and and then put the album out just
to let people experience the game
properly and he was trying to sort of
control
the the in the you know the consumption
and the hilarious side effect of that
was that because the game just happened
to have this crazy launch when we hit
the button the album exploded because it
had
two weeks worth of sales compressed into
the first day essentially uh
and um it was one of those things i was
like that's another one of those that in
hindsight i don't think i could possibly
duplicate that even with all the
planning in the world to to create this
sort of pent-up pressure in that way
especially because now
you know
someone will go into the game files and
it will end up online regardless so you
have to be the first to market if you
want to try to at least yeah cash that's
the same reason why i put all my stuff
on youtube immediately because i'm like
better at my channel than someone else's
uh you know because it will they will
and i don't i don't mind like they are
not they're not really doing any
measurable damage by doing so
um but um
but back then yeah it was still a little
a little different
and uh it's super interesting that's
you're right that
i mean journey is incredible but
even the the variable of the way that
sony was approaching indies at the time
is a factor in that that journey
couldn't have existed with the funding
necessarily if that that landscape
weren't exactly built to be the exact
way that it was i didn't realize it blew
up that fast because that seems like a
game like a bastion that would be a word
of mouth game
um but it
i i remember it was the third
installment with with utter respect to
be clear and it's an amazing game but it
was the third game from
what was a sony production process at
that point like yeah but i don't feel
like people know the other two like i
don't want to like adjudicate the word
indie but like it obviously had this
enormous marketing support and enormous
production support well they were
published so indie
as we've said that before yeah not
exactly like you can go crazy trying to
work yeah do those lines but my point is
like there was definitely like a boost
it had which is great i think that i
think yeah i wouldn't overestimate how
much flour
uh
helped launch it i know it did help but
flower
wildly eclipsed flow's sales and journey
wildly eclipsed flowers sales like each
one was
i'm making this up but each one was
seemingly in order of magnitude bigger
than the one yeah i wouldn't have
thought that 116 million units i think
exactly yeah it was a 100 percent attach
rate for everyone so i just looked it up
out of curiosity like you would
eventually buy a face of ps4
to touch to that um so the nintendo
switch has sold 92.87 million units
uh it's catching up to the wii
the is that all skews of this it's
catching up god it feels like it surely
would have surpassed the wii uh that's
that's also surprising too the wii has a
hundred and one louise so so they're
basically on parity with the j yeah
that's more successful than i thought
the wii was and that's less successful
than i thought the wii was a home
console for everybody's moms like it was
um
but it just shows you how much our
circle of friends are horrible
barometers of this because i feel like
no one that i talked to on a regular
basis
with very few people had wheeze and i
feel like everyone i know has a switch
you know what i didn't have a wii my mom
did so i used my mom's week
i didn't have one either until someone
gave me one for christmas like my
in-laws so it was it was one of those
where i i just and i was always a
nintendo fan but somehow the wii just
i'd had a gamecube
console like ever
at launch day
really you did because the the way it
shows what none of us know none of us
are in a position it's mainstream
successful that's the difference like
when we talk about it i feel like you
talk about like thinking right now the
ps4 if you ask like your average
hardcore gamer who's not looked at the
stats i feel like like ps4 it's got to
be up there the xbox 360 ps3
but it's actually the wii and the game
boy uh way higher because they were more
appealing to more people like video
games aren't niche but are at the same
time
uh you know nintendo as well occupies
its own game industry for sure next door
to the other game industry in fairness
yeah so the nintendo switch rules 92
million sales uh software sales is 681
million
but then
the highest selling trade that's a
really good attachment
the highest selling nintendo switch game
is
mario kart 8 deluxe with 38.7
million sales wow so that is like
that's a [ __ ] ton of titles that's a
whole that's over a third it's the
attach rate
for the first parties but you also buy
your fifas for your call of duty for
your gta yeah like it's not you're not
as beholden to the the platform holder
for your i would say even though sony's
first party is excellent obviously it's
not the only draw to owning a
playstation for the average consumer
yeah i have to say though a few years
ago ps4 just they could watch netflix
back in the day before every tv had
smart tv like that was you know totally
a thing that was actually why i my ps4
or three was was i bought blu-ray as a
blu-ray player kind of with equal
measure is the fact that i was a gamer
and also working on ps3 games like i
still
thought i'm not i don't need a separate
peripheral this is this pays for itself
on that basis alone it was super common
that people did that bought it as a
blu-ray player even though that that
wasn't that the blu-ray version super
expensive
no it was the backwards compatible the
whole thing felt bad i remember at the
time i was feeling like holy crap this
is this is brutal
um
but um what i was about to say is
regarding the those first party titles
um
it is interesting how
that is sort of the whole point right of
having first part is to help really kind
of incentivize
the the console purchase and and then
theoretically then you're gonna
have a higher likelihood of getting your
cross-platform games on the on the on
the uh
uh ps4 or five right or whatever and and
i remember
a few years ago they did a concert the
royal
um
the uh
royal philharmonic in london did a show
called um
playstation in concert at the at the
royal albert hall that was like a
retrospective of music from ps one two
three and four
and
see you know
i was i was there i was very lucky they
were playing some of my music but it but
but
the lineup of
pieces we think god it's crazy to think
that all of these were exclusives you
know from the from the history of the
god of war franchise and you know and
and um
um what else was on that uh that concert
uh uncharted of course the last of us
um you know the kill zone was our big
hillside i feel like
i feel like there was um does ratchet
crash bandicoot like yeah
metal gear
and and uh yeah it was mel guerra for an
exclusive every august on to the rapture
they were for a while weren't they i
think they were initially yeah
i love everybody's gone to the rapture i
was a huge fan of that game it's like
had such an effect on me like in a way
that i just didn't expect really really
enjoyed it
god me too i i consider myself a chinese
room fan because dear esther had the
same effect but in a more muted way and
then it was like they figured out they
like perfected their formula for rapture
and it sort of took all the things i
loved about
dear esther and and kind of blew it up
into something just so and dear lord
jess curry
um
what a score she wrote for that game
it's so unsettling in a
very i don't know delightful
rapture yeah
it's funny to me it's like it's like
soul affirming i wouldn't have i
wouldn't have million years thought to
label it as unsettling i found that game
super unsettling and so when the skull
kicked in i was like oh no soul that's
so interesting
everybody reminded you that i don't have
a soul yeah who's unsettled by that
that's that's my read i i have a weird
memory of i did because we because i
think that came out around the time it
might have been volume but we were doing
some we were doing a lot of the same
press events i just had a weird memory
of sitting with all the chinese room
people eating like little lunches in a
little room because you know press were
having a nice meal and we were all like
sat backstage like with these these
little cardboard box meals i just have
this strange
the least glamorous experience of my
career yeah it's really funny
yeah that's my only memory of that game
basically is is doing the little one she
had yeah i mean
it's also it's weird to me now to think
about the fact that in the 360 era
mass effect and bioshock
for both 360 exclusives
oh they were that's like in terms of
consoles though because i played both on
pc correct and then obviously they still
came to to ps4 anyway were they launch
at launch uh xbox exclusives like pc
came later i wouldn't in my memory both
of them came to pc at the same time i
just mean console exclusively we're
doing console
yeah
that is weird to think so weird that
that was part of the brand i'm thinking
that about playstation if you know i
hadn't hadn't thought about that before
that some of these exclusive game sales
are lower than the install base by a
significant margin
it's partly gotta be like we said it's
people playing madden and fifa and call
of duty and all the actually huge games
that everybody forgets about on the
street um and i wonder if that's just
part of the branding of like
you can look it at the sony first party
games even if you aren't going to play
them as part of a brand that makes it
seem very serious and mature for a lot
of them
and i wonder if that's the thing where
even if people aren't going to buy those
things it's valuable to sony on a
playstation to be like well yeah but
this is the identity of this brand it's
matua we have gritty video games
i've talked about this before right that
each of the consoles has a date of birth
in terms of like its age and it targets
so playstation has been targeting the
exact same core audience since you know
the guy who was coming home from the
club off for ps1 so all of the first
party stuff the spend on that was all
very much tied to club culture yeah at
least in europe i don't know if that was
the same in america but in europe all of
that was targeted that you know then the
ps2 comes and that person is like
a young professional so all the ads are
like you know people in offices like
being you know whisked off to other
worlds ps3 they're starting to you know
maybe have a family so the game starts
to be about like dads with young kids
and then like ps4 hits and like god of
war is about like old dad now yeah um
mps five is like your family game and
it's it's gonna continue all of those
first parties until eventually the ps8
and it's about uh
age and retirement and death and then
sony says we'll therefore make no more
playstations the cycle of life it's a
real like it's a it's a serious issue
with and this is something when you're
when your first party is so expensive
to develop is you do
if you if you want to target new
audiences which presumably you do that's
a very tricky ship to turn around
because you want to get if you're a sony
you want
20 uh you know people in their early 20s
to be excited by ps5 which is why you
see people you know putting so much
support into things like fortnite um
roblox hasn't happened on console yet
but i assume there's lots of
conversations that happened about that
um like there's you know there's an it's
actually really challenging for these
companies microsoft's the same you know
if you look at microsoft like there's a
reason halo infinite like is directly
basically it's not even a game based on
halo it's a game based on the box art
for the original halo like it's
literally that level of like specific
nostalgia yeah it's they're it's really
tricky this and this has to be a
challenge for them of how do we get
that younger audience into the consoles
because they are basically tailoring
themselves for an ever aging audience
more and more people you know enough
about biology you know that that's not
that's not an infinite plan
yeah it's uh
i i can't imagine what their jobs are
like and i'm glad i don't have to worry
about it but i had a conversation with
someone in youtube comments the other
day
who they theorized that did you do that
yeah why did you do that it's pretty
good i love you all i theorized that
most people on the street with the
uncharted movie coming out
um and obviously sushi movie coming out
as well
uh have no idea what goes to tsushima or
uncharted
and um
they vehemently disagreed with me of
course in a condescending way it was
like do you know what [ __ ] industry
you work in about people not knowing
uncharted so what i actually said was i
don't think that most people on the
street know who nathan drake is
uncharted i still think it's pretty
likely i think that you asked uh uh a
bunch of strangers on the street most
people are gonna have no idea what
nathan drake is what it's from no
concert i think uncharted would have a
similar like i think people would know
what uncharted nathan drake's got to be
even less than uncharted though and so
the idea that this movie is being made
to like appeal to mass audiences is some
ip that everybody knows it's like i
don't think that's true and alana do you
not know the industry that you work and
look how much money you make so out of
curiosity i went and looked up
how uh how much therapy i love
but i like i like statistics so i and
anytime i'm prompted to research
something i will evidently um
i looked up
the
highest grossing movie
of the year that uncharted 4 came out
which was captain america
and van figured out the average movie
ticket price i can't remember the
numbers that i came up with but the
yes video game industry makes more money
but the difference between the amount
like 100 to one in terms of audiences oh
my god like they're so much bigger and i
feel like yeah we've not worked out how
to sell a game for ten dollars so or to
everybody like that's part of it because
mobile games are the only
mobile games are the closest thing that
are an exception yeah you know i think
you go around the street and ask someone
if they know what wordle is they're
gonna know that you know that's more
likely yeah
yeah that's the thing that's why people
people scoff at mobile that this is why
genova
and in keeping with that trend uh where
i was saying that
you know flower was a bigger hit than
journey and and then
journey i mean then then flow and then
journey more than flower sky
their next game which people largely
don't know anything about here because
it's it is it is has it has like
i don't know i hope i'm not speaking out
of turn here but well over 100 million
active players it's
far and away that game company's most
successful title by probably several
orders of magnitude i mean their their
studio size journey shipped as a studio
like 14 people and i think they're north
of 100 now uh like
that game company is
is booming i haven't got that game
sky children of light right uh sky and
um
i did not work on it for the record
vince who also did flower he and i have
ping-ponged alternated with tgc titles
um yeah they spent they spent like seven
years making a mobile game after journey
came out it took them forever to get a
mobile game released and it's it's
gigantic and genova's whole thing was
you know look i'm very grateful to sony
and and we were able to make three games
in a row that were um
that were hugely uh uh you know they
made a big impact in the industry and
they they they were profitable and they
launched all our careers and that but at
the end of the day we're beholden to how
many people own a playstation
and he was like everyone owns a phone
can i bring an experience like journey
to the phone that was his fundamental
uh uh
goal and uh and by all marks they've
succeeded the audience size for sky even
though it's overwhelmingly in the asian
markets which is not surprising given
that it's a mobile game um
it is still
you know just the if the goal is to
reach number of people as movies do and
as tv does
um
mobile should be on everyone's mind i
think i said this to mike last week but
you can guarantee i reckon that all of
the um
platform holders uh nintendo's obviously
already done it extensively are going to
try to get their games on bubble um i
feel like xbox's strategy for that is
also pretty clear with cloud streaming
um less clear on what playstation or
sony's plan is but i have absolutely
zeroed out that every single one of your
your favorite franchises or ips will end
up on on mobile or as or as i said last
week or is already there and you just
don't know it yet like yeah that's the
other aspect right as an audience member
pathless simultaneously shipped on apple
arcade and yeah they had they had to
have a parallel sort of mini team within
giant squid figuring out how to
manipulate the mechanics of the game to
fit better with a
you know holding something and touching
the screen versus a controller but it's
fundamentally the same game and it's
crazy to think that this open world
you know
20-hour game uh
that you know sings and looks beautiful
on a ps5 can also run on an iphone
majority of a game that i
have ranted about a bunch of times
um now i'm forgetting the name of uh
it's a bird game you fly but
forgetting the name of it um oh no yes
thank you balcony i played majority of
the falconer on mobile uh even though i
was streaming it from my xbox um it's a
game poss game uh i played majority of
it through backbone which is an
attachment that i take with me pretty
much everywhere that you just plug into
either side of your iphone and it acts
as a controller it's really comfortable
there are a bunch of them but i really
like back buttons that essentially turn
your
your phone into a switch
sort of yeah it's really likely the the
background one i like the most because
also comes with an app where you open up
the backbone app and then you can just
like launch into whatever game you want
so i have my my playstation streaming
and my xbox streaming both built into
the backbone app so that you just click
on them and i can do it from anywhere so
i can connect to my xbox at home from
anywhere that i have wi-fi um and i mean
it's not great everywhere obviously but
uh i played yeah majority of that game
sitting on a couch while like watching
tv or movies or whatever just with the
backbone and it
it works like we're we're already there
like if that's a thing that i've already
done as somebody who's otherwise you
know been very disinterested in
mobile gaming then they've accomplished
that for sure and yeah like you said
austin everybody has a phone and
everybody has um all the hours that
they're spending on um social media
i don't doubt that marketing agencies
have access to that data and they're
like this person spent six hours on
twitter today and those six hours aren't
being monetized except by ads how can we
get those six hours so that's where
mobile mobile games got to come in and
try and sweep up the west
and i think they will
just hasn't happened yet and the and the
evidence is there that and
and i know that that game company's
whole crusade was
mobile doesn't have to have an implicit
quality
judgment attached to it like we we
currently make that assumption oh it's
monetized to high hell oh it's it's a
gambler addiction
framework this and that we have all
these kind of stigmas that we associate
with and you know not undeservedly in
many cases but but their attitude which
was the same when making flow flower and
journey and with regard to consoles is
it doesn't have to be the status quo
someone can make something that
challenges the kind of experience that
this platform is supposed to
theoretically deliver to you
and um it's tricky to break through
without a free game though that is still
very much the case there's not many i
mean the customer has learned you know
yeah exactly like i don't blame the
customer for that but i know we've
we're often asked to bring our games
over we've done it with a couple but
like
we found people don't want to pay
for our games at least on uh on the
phone like if you have any of your games
on mobile mic
uh thomas thomas loans on mobile or was
i think that's actually kind of decayed
off of all of the platforms because the
publisher hasn't hasn't updated it um
but uh we also had uh yeah we did um
subsurface circular as well um which
sub-service circular was you know got
lots of apple support and did okay but
you know would definitely was not as
strong on there as it was on switch or
on pc but we get a lot we get people
asking for like um specifically
solitaire that's what i was going to say
it seems like a safe bet
makes perfect sense but we would not we
would be laughed off the platform if we
tried to release uh ten dollars you'd
have to sell for two dollars
yeah no we'd have to sell we'd have to
get away for free and and sell each suit
or something we'd have to do some kind
of in-app purchase stuff which again
like i'm not i'm not casting shade on
that i don't think that's an implicitly
bad thing but it's definitely something
i'm not capable of designing well for
i've done free to play before you know
in the previous life before i went indie
and i was [ __ ] at it i i different
approach
i couldn't i couldn't design for it i
think that erica the fmb game that i
worked on
that was originally conceived of as a
mobile title he always
was the first prototype i saw was on the
phone for that yeah yeah it's like on an
ipad it was the idea is that it should
be
you know a good sized screen and it's
very much like their whole their tech
they're like patented or whatever
touch video like the whole point is it's
it is video that you're supposed to
touch literally
and play great on a phone yeah really oh
yeah it to this to the point that they
had to kind of make some interesting
compromises to make it because they made
a deal with sony and had it it had a
launch exclusivity on on playstation
that eventually broadened out to the
mobile they had to then report it back
to mobile
as it had been originally um conceived
and if i remember correctly the way it's
done on mobile is it's a free download
that only takes you so far into the game
and then effectively says chapters if
you want to keep playing
you know a couple bucks more or whatever
which i feel like is a brief that's
essentially kind of like
demos
that i used to play you know in the 90s
where you you know you'd play the first
ten remember playing the first i think
five minutes of
lucasarts full throttle
and uh it was free and i played that and
they sold a copy because of it like i
those first five minutes hooked me so i
feel like i like it i do like the
separation i i i struggle as a designer
to do free to play or or that kind of
in-app purchase simply because for me
and this is true of me as a player as
well i like kind of i like to pay for my
ticket and then once i'm in the theme
park or the theater entertain me
and i don't want to be thinking about
money again are you into the
all-inclusive resorts where you put your
wallet away as soon as you arrive i i
probably would be i've never been to one
but
yeah it did it recently i don't like i
don't like as a designer having to make
a decision between giving something
someone's giving someone something
special and like monetizing that in the
moment i'd
rather modular men
like your games are not very modular
some games lend themselves really well
to that from a design standpoint like if
you're okay
but it's i when i've worked on those
kind of games other companies i've
always struggled because i just i just
can't like intellectually kind of solve
how to like a different style
yeah but is that something that you
think about it's not a moral thing it's
just like do you do you just talk about
that
like actively knowing how much money
there is on mobile and the size of the
install being somebody who is
effectively like a i don't want to call
you a small business owner it seems
bigger than small but you run a company
and you're trying to get people paid uh
what is that something
you're calling me a small business well
it's fine
it's a small business mike's got too
many products and people i don't know
what i would consider a small business
but i don't feel like bithell games is a
small business
i like i like money bags performing as
well yeah money bags mike
yeah you just put out a bunch of uh
job listings
i did which has been that has been a
process yes going through all of those
we need to do an episode at some point
about like getting a job in the games
industry that would be a theme that
people might be interested in i have
lots of advice
about what not to do
do you think about mobile like is it
something that you're like oh we should
do this do you feel pressure for it we
think about it yeah like for exactly the
reasons you're saying like there's
enough there's a we'd be foolish if we
didn't but the problem for us has always
been that the kind it's like austin said
like the kinds of games i tend to make
or that my team tend to make or that the
people we work with tend to make
just don't lend themselves to that kind
of breaking up and and piecemeal thing
because we cannot release a game and
whenever you say that whenever i say
that in public or tweet or whatever
there will be people who are like i'll
give you a fiver i'd give you attendance
like i really appreciate that but there
has to be a lot more of you to justify
the cost of doing it and unfortunately
it seems like
there are there are obviously exceptions
to the rule but generally that's not how
it's done so for us it's something we
talk about every now and again um i'm
sure we'll probably do it again cause
it's it's actually a really pleasurable
experience doing a mobile version of a
game
you avoid so much of the those systems
are so much smoother usually than
console back ends and stuff so it's
actually quite nice often to do a port
mobile it can be quite an enjoyable
experience
in a nerdy way but i would never have
guessed yeah it's
yeah no it's way easier um
and and that's so it's it's it's fun to
do but no it's a it's uh
it's just finding the right thing and i
think to be honest when
when people when people from the console
or pc site go to the mobile side in kind
of an arrogant way and go you know we've
we've got real games we're going to
bring one of our real games over it
always falls on its ass because they
don't know the audience they don't know
the marketplace they don't know anything
about it there's an arrogance that often
kind of comes over with with people
coming from different spaces so
if we were to do a mobile game it would
be from the ground up plan for mobile
thought through mobile you know much
like that games company seems to have
done that with that game like we would
be actively coming to the system on its
own terms and that audience on what they
want you know um i think i think yeah
i've seen too many developers fail by
like going yeah we're just gonna we're
gonna bring our first person shooter to
mobile and it'll be exactly the same and
real gamers and all this stuff and it's
like i'm not sure that's true
a very cool thing about this uh sorry
austin about sky um that's on their
wikipedia so it's called sky children of
light like you said
and they've held a bunch of in-game
events in support of charity and have
raised millions of dollars um through
in-game events
in sky which is super cool they've done
earth day um so they have in-app
purchases where each in-app purchase was
used to plant one tree
um that resulted in 40 000 trees being
planted in the amazonian australian
forest damaged by wildfires and then in
may 2020 they did days of healing
um they raised
719 000 for covered crisis fund
and then june they did days of rainbow
event uh raising money for pride and
raise 794 thousand dollars which
is
so cool like well so you know the basis
of their the basis of their monetization
is buying things for other players uh no
so it's that's nice it's nice
yeah it's it's less about
i can have this cool you know like in
star trek fleet command i can i can get
that cool ship i want or i can mine
resources faster it's like
you know i can i can give this person
this gift um
and you know deck out their space that
kind of thing that's so cool
consistently speaking i don't know the
full extent of how their monetization
works um i just know that was part of
that was part of the initial idea from
the earliest days that that i heard
about it
um it also has very good review scores
but it's interesting to note that like
it didn't get on all the main
publications that your average
i don't know what a console pc game
would like it's on edge game informa
uh it is on a lot of them actually it's
but it's stuff like nintendo live pocket
gamer um it's not it doesn't have as
many reviews on metacritic as
we're used to for even like your aaa
entry that's on console or pc which i
guess well it only came to switch last
summer yeah um and i don't actually have
any idea i assume it's on
xbox and playstation but i it's i mean
it's for sure a mobile game at its core
so
it's not on
playstation yet okay yeah it's also
worth noting that like the review that
they've tried like there's definitely
like outlets that have tried to cover
mobile games and do reviews and do
previews and stuff like that and it just
doesn't ever seem to drive the traffic
right like the audience on mobile they
don't really care what like
they're just gonna go website
they're going to play it for free
they're going to find off themselves or
they're going to wait for a
recommendation from a mate oh you just
look in the store and there's not about
look to authority yeah you see how many
stars it has on the store and that's all
you need really you know it's like
because i always look and i say oh this
is four stars but 500 000 reviews like
that's a pretty thorough sample size for
my taste you know click
that's battle
whereas gamers look to critics still
like a gamer like gamers really care
what like the metacritic is or what the
ign score is or whatever like they
really really care in a way that's not
true of that that more mainstream
audience
austin before we head off today i wanted
to ask because we've like kind of
touched on it here um how did you get
the brand do you need to know
how did you feel about last week's uh uh
news you said when we were organizing
you didn't have a ton of input but like
did you have any
any about microsoft yeah about microsoft
purchase uh i i
uh it doesn't surprise me uh i mean it
surprises me in the obvious ways but at
the same time it's like of course these
things happen and
and uh and uh uh
but yeah i remember thinking you know i
i of course first thought i always
wonder is what
implications this might have for
uh my end of things uh just from the
standpoint that
part of the way a composer makes their
way through the business is that
different publishers
have different internal norms and
sometimes that can be leveraged to your
advantage where it's like well you know
this studio i'll just make something up
like ubisoft gave me this and now i'm
talking to you
microsoft
and uh you know
these deal terms or whatever we're fine
with them
you know how much of a conversation can
we have about them that sort of thing
and there's a healthy
uh thing that emerges where everybody
having kind of their own take sort of
you know it's kind of like genetic
diversity in the world of evolutionary
biology like you want the maximum amount
um and so
there is of course
the aspect of well if more and more
places are going to do business the way
microsoft does
that would potentially have implications
because there's definitely i can't say
any specifics but there's certainly
things that microsoft does differently
than anybody else
and that would just mean that many more
titles are going to follow suit that way
so i remember looking at that and going
that'd be interesting i don't know it's
so speculative if or how that would
matter or if they would even get
involved in those kinds of things in
their for their subsidiaries at that
point but
um
but uh
you know all the
rest of my reaction was basically
just wait and see i don't i don't uh
i don't um to be clear
i don't know what's gonna happen
yeah it's hard to say you know where
anyone who tells you a certainty about
the future of the games industry right
like those are the people to stop
listening to yeah i saw a friend of mine
on twitter just an hour ago right i want
to pitch a gdc talk that does a recap of
every prior gdc talk that made bold
predictions about the future of the
industry and got it wildly wrong yeah um
you know like everything now is all
about this or is all about that and uh
and um
single player's dead single player is
all that matters single player is dead
yeah exactly yeah yeah um yeah so i i
they're you know you could do a lot and
that's not to say that there's some
people in the world whose job it is to
make those predictions and they
hopefully are
you know m moderately more informed uh
than the rest of us in doing something
right so good like there's a lot like
packed us right more than often than
he's wrong you know those kind of people
there are there are some that are wrong
occasionally but like there's a lot or
more often but like they're the odds
usually on the predictors i would say
hector is usually pretty on point
but you can't be perfect that's not how
that kind of thing works and yeah i mean
that's a lot of what mike and i said
last week and and we both got some
tweets about it where i was just like
well if i didn't comment on this it's
because i have no [ __ ] idea what i'm
talking about
like that they want to be possible
you're smart you're not smart if you
unless you say with absolute certainty
exactly what's going to happen then
you're an idiot
also to be fair
uh i i didn't
i wasn't here last time because i had
nothing to say that was incidental
i i had already booked that time with
something oh yeah yeah and i mean we
organized it austin said [ __ ] you alana
in the texts and i was very offended
like he was just incredibly rude and
dismissive um it's a shame it's a shame
now
yeah that's quite correct i think
alana's being very big frankly having
you back on the show austin after what
you said well i had to i had to there
was a paypal related uh
transaction
no i i i also i watched i sat through
all 49 or whatever minutes of your grant
uh video very curious um
waiting just looking for that thing i
can exploit sadly neither of you gave me
anything but i will i will there was one
thing that that he glossed over that you
raised that and i thought in 30 seconds
if i can remember it i will put this to
bed he talked about how something he
worked on and i can't remember what it
was if it was banjo-kazooie or something
ended up in a tv show where they were
playing it okay they were playing on
screen and he made royalties from that
and there was something about the way
you phrased it that made it sound like
oh it's a good thing somebody mentioned
blah blah blah that like as if that was
sort of good luck on his part that that
that was a known
yeah so
the thing was that it wasn't visible in
the episode nor was it audible in the
episode but somebody had written down on
some sheet somewhere that it was
banjo-kazooie that he was playing and
thus he got royalties for it yeah and so
just for the sake of
broadcasting some insider education to
the universe
that is definitely contractually
required uh that is def and whenever a
film or a tv show
is
like the the world of publishers in film
and tv is referred to as distributors
but it's the same thing a video game
publisher is a movie distributor they're
the same fundamental concept of
give us your content we will bring it to
the world um and pop and distributor
deliverable requirements have what's
called a cue sheet which is a
spreadsheet that lists
every single piece of original and
licensed music in that with all the
uh the writer the writer or writers and
whoever controls the publishing
interests on that piece of music whether
it's a record label or a music publisher
and has all of their information logged
and then this gets blasted out to
organizations that track
tv and and theatrical broadcasts and
stuff all over the world through what
are called performance royalty
organizations like in the us we have
ascap and bmi and csac in the uk of prs
et cetera et cetera
is going to turn
i know them
seriously what's going on
the sun's reflecting on the building
that is directly across from there
your whole
contrast shifted dramatically like burst
into flame and you said so all of a
sudden why at 2 20 pm how strange
because i i bring it up because i have
the same thing my thing was if it's if
it's not audible
i actually assumed that
nobody was actually playing
banjo-kazooie
it just means someone was low in the mix
it was it just means that they licensed
it they got the clearance to put it in
their thing and then when they went to
go make their final actual mix it's down
so low that you for all intents and
purposes can't hear it but i guarantee
you they did because i had the exact
same thing happen where i was i you get
these quarterly statements of
of here are the royalties you earned and
most of them it's you know if you make
good money it's because you have a
billion one penny transactions because
so much of it is you know just a little
money here a little money there uh
and like little pennies uh of you know a
movie that i scored a little independent
movie that i scored played on tv in
lithuania here's your six dollars uh
that kind of thing so that's why it's
all about long-term growing of a catalog
more than it is the one big score
although i knew a guy in my youth who
always had uh always had beer money
because he was an extra in gladiator wow
well yeah
he was friday nights basically
yeah so i some hulu show that i never
heard of there's a scene where a guy is
playing assassin's creed syndicate and
and it is you do see a flash of it on
screen so they do
license
uh the the game and and and including in
that they separately licensed
my score because i never heard of this
thing and i got like nine cents for some
hulu show where i was like what what is
and i went and i pulled it up and i
cranked my speakers as loud as they
would go which is scary because they get
very loud and i could
barely hear anything i definitely would
never been able to identify
that it was mine but the guy is playing
syndicate so they anyway i just wanted
to make it again devs if it strikes you
as unreasonable that you don't get a cut
every time a game you worked on is on tv
then that's a really good reason to look
into the differences between the history
of the music industry and the games
industry and what composers have done
over the years in order to get those
rights
just i'd go a bit lefty for a second
though you know the funny thing is that
it's not through unionization because
it's
composers are forbidden from unionizing
in the u.s
right but some but some composers made
that happen by taking action to do so
there's no question that that
that
um
performance royalties are a thing that
were involved legislatively in their in
their creation although i do believe it
is not actually legally required it is
just industry best practice um that is
it is considered a default minimum but
there's no enforcement agency associated
with that like you can't sue
uh if if somebody denies you those
royalties if assuming that it's
contractually okay that they deny you
that obviously you can sue if you if
they break the contract but i think that
it's basically just i could be slightly
wrong
uh but i'm pretty sure that like
the the rates are set in terms of what
just broadcasts broadcasters have to pay
but i do believe that um
that uh you know if if uh
sony pictures hires me to score a
spider-man movie they are not legally
required to give me what's referred to
as the writer's share the 50 of the
royalties that that music generates
would be retained by me as the writer
they would keep the other 50
as the distributor as the publisher but
i don't think they're required to do so
it's just that's the way business is
done and they know that if if they try
to break that
you know it's more drama than it's worth
basically
so it's not it's not unionization but
via pressure applied by the larger group
you maintain certain rights in addition
to your legal rights
but it's not a union
are you saying that is if you think i'm
anti-union
no no no i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying it's very uniony i'm saying
it's very it's union adjacent yeah it's
the idea of action for the individual
yeah i have no i have no uh
for a long time i was a proud member of
the musicians union which is adjacent to
the uh you said it's composers aren't
allowed to be in union we're considered
we're considered employers more than
employees so that's right oh that makes
sense yeah you're managers so yeah you
you're not allowed yeah that's a good
point it's it's not by law it's not
legislatively that way and it's not even
a supreme court precedent it's a
it's like a federal court one layer
below and it never got appealed but it
is considered the default standing at
the moment and they've tried repeatedly
to overturn that the teamsters even
agreed to to uh to be the sort of
catalyzing force to unionize composers
but
um
but it's uh it's never it's never worked
but the musicians union the performers
the recording musicians
uh you know conducting orchestration all
of that there are union
uh
like that that is a union job for sure
it's just it's impressive what we can do
when we work collaboratively to enforce
norms or create norms huge fans to treat
people better hey i was on the board of
directors for years of the society of
composers and lyricists for that exact
reason eventually they just had too many
meetings i couldn't keep up with it so i
was like i gotta focus on my own career
guys but but that was it was amazing
because a lot of the other folks on the
board you know like charles bernstein
who's you know the original composer of
nightmare on elm street and people like
that who have been around the business
for a long long time and they've seen
all the trends and the rises and falls
and when the going's been good and
they're going so bad and the insights
that you get from hanging out with a
group like that
is
is incredible and absolutely drives home
the idea that you know
as as composers that you know the few
thousand of us that there are kind of
and even less potentially if you just
restrict it to us but thinking globally
it's such a niche thing that absolutely
it's in our interest to try to figure
out what are some things that we can
kind of collectively agree on and try to
you know if not standardize at least
um suggestively evangelize
uh
and i'm i i'm all for that
that's great no that's and that's and i
think that's the there's a lesson in
that to other creatives in other fields
including video games for sure yeah
um on that note hi everybody welcome to
play watch listen i'm alan pierce i'm a
video game writer that that that's mike
bithell he's a video game director and
that's also wintery he's a video game
composer troy is not here uh troy's in a
session this morning yeah i don't speak
on behalf of him uh but because people
have asked i have no intention of
kicking troy off of this show there's
definitely not a thing that i have any
intention of doing um but i don't
imagine he's spending a whole lot of
time on twitter right now from my
perception
he and i he and i are working on a thing
together that is heavily
monopolizing uh our time that's true i
know like before the the episode we
recorded with him he had mentioned
having to disappear for the next month
for something anyway
um yeah but yeah yeah his dance card is
wild structure it's very very very full
that's good cool
um we will see you all next week